ton
et
le boeuf c'est dans l'adn de l'alberta
[Musique]
on
c'est un moteur économique est une
industrie profondément ancré dans son
territoire
le choix est clair cela les plaines
canadienne et en n é 1001 d'histoire
concert que c'est une grâce c'est une
prairie
c'est ici à deux heures au nord de
calgary que blake et sa famille ont
choisi de s'installer pour élever des
bus vous vous produisez combien de
battre par année on va vendre 40
êtes vous capable de vivre et servez
votre famille avec 40 belle blake n'a
pratiquement que la rotation des enclos
de pâturage à faire il fait partie de
ces rares producteurs qui élève du boeuf
nourri exclusivement à l'aide
on utilise presque pas de machine
on n'utilise aucun produit chimique par
contre élevé un boeuf au pâturage
demande plutôt son bétail ne grossit pas
aussi vite que le boeuf traditionnels
maintenant les producteurs herbert ten
ont la chance pour rabat et leur boeuf
sur la ferme dans le champ pas de stress
de l'animal et je vois que ça c'est plus
en plus important pour les consommateurs
a acquis qu'on vend l'unc a milité
pendant plus d'une décennie pour en
arriver là
c'est en juillet dernier que le
gouvernement albertain a autorisé les
petits producteurs à abattre directement
à la ferme un avantage pour lui qui
offre aussi ses services de boucherie
mobile pour les fermiers du coin mais il
faut que les consommateurs achètent nos
aînés animal entier
en travaillant de la sorte blake n'est
plus dépendant des deux grands abattoirs
de l'alberta qui ont été fortement
ébranlés en tant qu vide ce qui n'a pas
été le cas pour les éleveurs
traditionnels comme kelly smith fraser
[Musique]
des producteurs traditionnels se sont
retrouvés avec un prix à la baisse pour
chacune de leurs bêtes alors que le prix
du boeuf à l'épicerie lui augmenté en
alberta il ya plus de boeuf que
d'humains élevé par dix-huit mille
producteurs répartis un peu partout à
travers la province
[Musique]
la grande majorité élèvent leurs animaux
à l'herbe avant de les transférer dans
d'immenses parcs d'engraissement pour
lui seront nourris au grain avant d'être
abattu le géant américain ken guile et
le brésilien jbs abate transforme 7000
bovins par jour en alberta c'est
représente 75% du boeuf au pays
[Musique]
direction l'université de l'alberta à
edmonton pour rencontrer hélène godard
professeur spécialisé en économie de
l'agriculture
mais le boeuf canadien n'ait pas
apprécié qu au pays plus de 50 % de
notre production est exporté à
l'international ce qui représente près
de 3 milliards de dollars 1 bis cause
[Musique]
matthieu paris vente sans relâche ici
comme à l'étranger les particularités du
boeuf de l'alberta au nom de tous les
élevages qui vraiment bon dans le boeuf
canadien c'est le standard de qualité
qui existe peu importe de quelle partie
du canada leboeuf a été élevé ou ou
abattus c'est un caïd est qui qui existe
qui est un standard en retard une ombre
dans chaque province
pourtant c'est encore presque impossible
de savoir si le boeuf que vous achetez
au comptoir des viandes est vraiment
canadiens doivent canada canada 3 ou
canada 38 sont des normes des standards
de qualité ou des lieux d'abattage et
non des preuves de provenance ainsi sans
le savoir on peut acheter au comptoir du
boeuf des états unis ou de l'australie
un boeuf américain pour avoir la
certification canadiennes comme il passe
les normes canadiennes à ce point là
c'est du boeuf canadien
ok une fois qui est abattu au canada il
devient un boeuf canadien c'est le boeuf
canadien qui est tapé dessus ici au
canada ça fait partie de la du terme
c'est qui c'est quoi le boeuf canadien
c'est un animal abattu ici au canada
puisque boeuf canada fait la promotion
de cette viande si exceptionnel on
n'aurait pas intérêt à créer un logo à
s'assurer que les consommateurs sachent
qu'ils vont manger du boeuf canadien
l'abattoir à une carcasse
quelque 1500 1600 livres
c'est un peu un projet vraiment énorme à
décortiquer à trouver des marchés
pendant une journée ton à 4000 carcasses
qui passent par là par la production
fait que fait que vraiment être capable
de dire ça sans ce stade là c'est un
système canadien très difficile à
certifier jusqu'à la table du
consommateur canadien à la suite en mai
selon helen goddard l'absence de
provenances sur l'emballage est
peut-être al avantage d épicerie de
grosses ristournes en 2020 le prix moyen
de la viande de boeuf a augmenté de 7 %
au pays
malgré cela malgré la qu'ovide malgré
les recommandations du guide alimentaire
canadien il malgré notre volonté de
manger moins de viande
les ventes au pays n'ont pas diminué au
contraire ça a été une année vraiment
extraordinaire pendant la coved les
ventes de boeuf ont augmenté oui
notre consommation de boeuf au pays
auraient augmenté de près de 4% en 2020
selon boeuf canada et cette industrie
génère chez nous 18 milliards de dollars
alors peu importe la méthode de
production l'élevage de boeuf en alberta
n'est pas près de disparaître
[Musique]